Bobby fiser had planned on bringing his
Knight to D7 very common move as far as
development um he later on is going to
get this Knight you know kicked off to a
different square but for now this is a
completely fine square and from here
burn decides to bring his Rook to D1 you
always want to put your Rooks behind
pawns as they push up the board and so
this is a logical move to bring his Rook
to D1 now keep in mind that his Queen
was here before so this Knight here on
F3 at some point could be pinned down
with the bishop on G4 once this queen
went away from D1 um the pin could no
longer be there but now that the Rook is
here on D1 we may see a pin later on
down the road with the bishop to G4 here
now from here Bobby fer decided to bring
his Knight to B6 again getting a Tempo
this Queen's going to have to move here
obviously he's being attacked and so um
yes Bobby Fischer is moving his minor
piece twice you never want to move one
of your pieces twice unless you have a
good reason for it and one of those
reasons is to gain a temp